APPROPRIATE THAT WE ALL WILL
BEGIN OUR HEARING ART TODAY FOR
THE SENATE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE
BILL BUT I WANT TO GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH QUORUM SO SECRETARY
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
RICARDO HERE TITLE HERE STONE
DOWN HERE BELL MEL HERE JACKSON
JACKSON HERE PAN WIENER. WINNER
HERE. BUT MEMBERS WE HAVE FIVE
MEMBERS PRESENT HAS BEEN
ESTABLISHED AND AT THIS MOMENT
WE ARE GOING TO END. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO IS HERE TO PRESENT.
HELLO HOW ARE YOU GOOD IS NOT
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU
ARE READY TO GO THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB ELEVEN EIGHTEEN
THE H. FROM THE CALIFORNIA ACT
RECENT AMENDMENTS A LINE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTEEN WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
CALLING ON THE SECRETARY OF THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
AGENCY TO DEVELOP THE MASTER
PLAN ON AGING SPECIFICALLY THIS
BILL WOULD DIRECT THE SECRETARY
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA APPLY TO BE A MEMBER
OF A. R. P.'S NETWORK OF AGE
FRIENDLY STATES AND COMMUNITIES
AS A MEMBER OF THE NETWORK
CALIFORNIANS CALIFORNIA WILL
DEMONSTRATE ITS COMMITMENT TO
OUR AGING POPULATION BY
ENCOURAGING STATE POLICYMAKERS
PARTNERS AND DEVELOPERS TO USE
AARP'S COLLECTION OF RESOURCES
INCLUDING EXAMPLES. OF THE BEST
PRACTICES TOOL KITS DATA AT THE
LIVABILITY INDEX TO DEVELOP
COMMUNITIES IN IN A TIMELY
MANNER. MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES ALREADY SEE THE
IMPORTANCE OF UTILIZING THE H.
FAMILY NETWORK AS A PATH
FORWARD TO CITY PLANNING
INCLUDING SAN FRANCISCO.
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES SAN
DIEGO WAS HOLLYWOOD IN CINEMA
COUNTY JUST TO NAME A FEW. BY
TWENTY THIRTY AT OUR END
ADDITIONAL FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE OVER SIXTY
FIVE YEARS OLD. IT IS CRITICAL
WE ACT NOW TO ENSURE THIS
POPULATION AS WELL AS PEOPLE OF
ALL AGES BUT WILL ENJOY. LIVING
IN AN AGE FAMILY STATE. ARE
WITH ME TODAY IS JAMES CROSS ON
BEHALF OF A. R. P. TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OR ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OF COMMITTEE MAY
HAVE. A MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ADD A
RP IS BEEN WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. UP TO
AND INCLUDING AFTER THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER. OF CREATING
Vì A PROCESS FOR A PLAN FOR
AGING. AND WEHAVE BEEN ASSURED
THAT THEY FEEL THIS DOES FIT
VERY WELL WITH IN. THEIR GOALS
AS THEY DEVELOP THE MASTER PLAN
SO I WANT YOU ALL FEEL THE
VEHICLE FEEL SURE THAT. THIS
DOES FIT WITHIN THAT LONG RANGE
PROCESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE DO HAVE A MOTION. UP AT
AT THE AT THIS MOMENT WILL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE ANYONE WHO WANTS
TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS BILL.
IS THERE ANYONE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL THE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK.
NOW. OKAY I DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER FURTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION OKAY. DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU YES I KNOW
IT'S LATE I JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR DOING THIS I BROUGHT
THE BILL I CAN'T REMEMBER THE
NUMBER NOW IT'S TOO LATE. TO
CREATE A MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
THE GOVERNOR IT HAS CREATED A
COMMISSION THE BASICALLY
FOLLOWS THOSE GUIDELINES
OBVIOUSLY WERE RECOGNIZING HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS SO WE DO THIS
MUCH MY ONLY QUESTION IS WHAT.
DO WE EXPECT TO SEE OR GET FROM
THE A RP AS PART OF THIS ORGAN
A AS PART OF THIS COLLECTIVE IF
YOU WILL. THANK YOU OF THE
JACKSON IN ESSENCE WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT CREATES. WHAT THEY
CALL DOMAINS WERE STANDARDS
THAT BECOME PART OF THE
PLANNING PROCESS OUR MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE ADOPTED THESE
ALREADY THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH ALSO BELIEVES THAT
IT CAN INCORPORATE THESE. AS
YOU KNOW FROM THE TIME YOU
SPEND ON THESE ISSUES AS YOU
PLAN COMMUNITIES AND YOU THINK
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF THE AGING
POPULATION THE DISABILITY
POPULATION THAT MATTER YOU'VE
GOT TO START BUILDING THOSE
INTO A PLANNING PROCESS.
THROUGH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION DID WITH A RP AND
WE BELIEVE BY ADOPTING THESE WE
WILL BE VERY MUCH A PART OF. IN
THAT KIND OF THINKING. THANK
YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS NO SEEN
NONE OF. A SIMILAR ROOM WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS IMPORTANT BILL AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. OKAY THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER. AND THAT MOTION IS.
THAT THE BILL BE RETURNED TO
THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
CONSIDERATION. THE SECTOR CAN
YOU ARE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. A
TITLE HI RICARDO I STONE STONE
NO BELL BELL I JACKSON JACKSON
HIGH PAN. PAN AYE WIENER WIENER
AYE FIVE ONE. SO THE BO IS FIVE
ONE OF THE BILL ITSELF THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THAT ENDS OUR C.
SENATE. HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE HEARING TO VENT OVER